that's the way fashion is made not to
the press not through designers or
anything else
it's made for people i think now they're
recognizing
that he single-handedly changed american
fashion
i've always had a big known clientele on
all different levels
and that is always always helps the
business the people that have
more public attention like eliza
minnelli or elizabeth taylor or lauren
bacall
in the end result the client makes it
fashionable in other words if somebody
that's in the public eye wears your
things it causes attention to them and
perhaps other people might want to look
that way
i remember mrs onassis who was mrs
kennedy in those days
came to me and wanted to look like a
woman on the street she didn't want to
look like
you know mrs kennedy and she came and
you know we made an
enormous wardrobe of things so she would
look rather simple and could
walk down the street without being
noticed oh new york in 1957 was the most
terrific place i'd ever seen
i was a young man when i first came to
new york and it was a land of fantasy
style beauty glamour safety
everything all day and all night it was
just the most wonderful place i'd ever
been in my life
i came from the midwest and coming to
new york was just like
the land of opportunity it was the dream
that was always
wanting and it was finally fulfilled i
always wanted to change everything in
clothing to make it a little more simple
to make it a little more american
to make it more contemporary and newer
and always a point of difference
and that's the only thing that makes a
designer become important
and that's the only way that you really
create a style and
you have a signature it was a fashion
that was to bridge the gap between the
very fancy end of
the fashion business the hot couture for
lack of a better word they're ready to
wear things so people could look
you know very interesting and look like
they had some quality clothing on
and look different than you know the
average cool
a client or the average ready-to-wear
client it was very special it was like
you were the only one that had it you
know it was a major breakthrough and you
know it
really changed the look of fashion
totally it's helped me help myself this
is something that i needed very
very much you know the particular point
in my career because
my business was growing so very fast i
wasn't able to do
all of the legal obligations and the
financial aspects of the business and i
needed a larger
corporate structure to help me out so it
really helped me help myself to free me
to do more
which i was able to do i think it only
enhances the wholestone
to reach a broader public is a much more
interesting challenge
than to reach a few and it's a very
interesting and i think healthy
challenge
it hasn't been a problem so far and i'm
quite a good producer of revenue he was
great he was like a big brother to me
he dressed me before cabaret
i knew him since i was 19. he protected
me
he was supportive he was always there
he was just wonderful it's kind of a
ruthless business
fashion as is showbiz as is any business
you know
journalism any all businesses are fairly
ruthless but
the fashion industry is really ruthless
i think now they're recognizing
that he single-handedly changed american
fashion
he made it clean
and elegant he was a minimalist
he made women look beautiful and the
clothes
they wore the clothes the clothes didn't
wear them
he's being recognized and now for really
what he contributed
which was enormous
you